so this is to cut a woman's hair and you
know looking at you I just never liked
your haircut would you like some of mine
okay so I'm just gonna still wear this
because you know I want to be pretty and
wait wait wait I'm like totally
beautiful now I'm in profit it just does
almost work for him okay regardless okay
so they had this whole thing like you
know let's let's have like that cover
all the hair when you take it off it'll
be like old luscious and flowing and
it's like yeah but my baldness rejected
it so okay so yeah this is to cut a
woman's hair and this is one where they
come across a witch who is sitting on
Jake and wants a princess's hair because
it's the prettiest and she has this huge
bald spot and one spin to go get it so
he's going he's trying to cut princess's
hair but they all think that like he's
hitting on them and he's not and sure
enough at the very end he decided to go
to Princess Bubblegum I guess kind of
seduces her like in like what ten
seconds someone yeah like it's the most
forceful um pretty much the most
forceful wooing and she goes along with
it but I couldn't catch whether or not
she was like just oh of course I like
you like a friend thing or if it was
like you know like yes I like you like
something more
but regardless whatever she gives him a
bit of her hair which is just bubblegum
and at the very end the witch's said
it's like oh I'll never have hair and
fins like why don't you take some of my
takes off the head and has like first
time you seen without the Hat are you
just stealing this along super long
flowing
hair and he's like take it as like
totally bald which is like how long must
you have been growing that stuff and
it's just like damn it shaved off and
everything and then she's gonna do evil
but she trips and hurts herself and they
laugh she sprained a branch
yes Brenda branch so I guess the like
the the two real interesting things
kinda I guess is that a he may or may
not now be seeing bubblegum which is
interesting you know it's like or did
she just like not read it that way at
all that that I'm kind of curious about
and then be yeah he has super long
blonde hair which I want to say I kind
of knew I think because a DVD cover who
because they showed a little bit of it
um but yeah you guys are all talking
like you can't wait for him to see it I
can't wait I say is that were you
talking about the hair yes yeah oh no no
that honestly I didn't see it comin
anyway it was more that it's more I had
a little bit of an idea because I had
DVD yeah but uh they're still funny you
know something it's like what's up there
is ad and it's like just have like this
super cool how the hell's he keep it
under there as you can see it's not very
easy I'm tired of wearing this actually
if you why does she need it is that the
doors right yeah why does she use these
are gonna long brown hair
but you already go long brown hair
longer that's what it is okay what
actually a friend of ours Vanna
she's got like this long black hair and
at cons she I don't know how she does it
she will wrap it up into her under this
wig that's about this long and you
wouldn't even be able to know she had
that long of hair but can she do it in
an adventure time probably yeah because
she goes into the lorax tako system or
hexa her character from The Lorax oh the
once-ler know curious how she could pull
off more sexy Laura
because if I guess she takes all that
hair and hides it and she does it like
perfectly it's how crazy can be done
could you do that Jory with our joke
you're not in this one but you kind of
just brought her in anyway
yeah good job I'll catch you next time
or not get you next time to keep you out
anyway um I'm serving those two things
that was okay not one that particularly
stands out to be except for those two
things one of them may not have even
happened with the whole Bubblegum thing
what about the the princess that died of
baldness that oh okay yeah that was good
to the the grave thing you mean right
yeah thank you bye
yeah just there's this skeleton it's
just like you know - and how does she
know him and then like she just sort
gets up and walks away it's just like oh
thanks a lot
that's that's it glad the clothes kept
intact so no way or anything but that's
my only problem with the episode though
it took them no time to dig up that
grave it takes to dig up a grave a long
time and I quite like a ninja something
else no just something else in the
episode not about grave digging oh I say
I do you like the overall theme of it
that the which is evil inside and out it
doesn't matter if you're pretty on the
outside you're gonna be ugly on the
inside and outside doesn't matter yeah
actually that was sort of a nice little
speech fib has at the end it's like you
know you are ugly and but it's not just
the outside it's you're inside you know
this is making this now look good in
sort of thing and yeah I guess that's
are what convinces him to hand over the
hair to because she's like I have screw
it oh she does admit you're right you
know this is kind of how I am I'm sorry
it sucks and he's like okay now I'll
help you I kind of like a little bit the
that she can grow branches I'm like her
hands and stuff like that that's a penis
wide track with the Barbie yeah you know
that was and she know I've been really
funny if the butterfly was the butterfly
from the last that would be like a real
I almost said them what been like really
enjoyment done it they they have a lot
of those anyway if they have the snail
in every episode that's true um so yeah
I I think I think a spaghetti dinner
would have wound you um no but I'm not a
princess made of bubblegum so maybe it's
I I know I know it look very bubblegum
ish but
yeah I like the urgency of how I'd say
it just my brain just like okay tank
I like the urgency of him like they just
need chairs for that they go like cut
down the tree like get the bits of the
log up just like go over as I could put
your buck there hey yeah Jason with a
wife and kids it's like why goodie bring
and the lit candle yeah like they bring
a chair cut down a tree oh I see that's
something that I really like and it's
really again minor that's one thing I do
like he chops on the tree and it slams
to the ground when it cuts to Princess
Bubblegum and you hear chop chop like
just Jun Jie's when it cuts back that he
now has the touch like extra things for
chairs like instead of it just falling
in them being there they actually have
that extra sound effect it shows he
actually yeah actually chopped those
pieces off like that sound I think it
just made their no I like that it's
something small that you know adds a
little bit more depth to it and the UFO
in the background where's the UFO man
right at the beginning after he's
feeding the birds well when they landed
they start walking there's a UFO in the
background okay oh yeah oh I like it
crashed in the woods no like it's a it's
just a crashed UFO in the yeah in the
woods in the background I totally missed
that
again it is part of the fun is just
trying to find the cool little things in
the background like that
um but yeah all I got on this fight it
was okay you know what is the the witch
woman remind me a little bit of the
lawyer
no no ah of the Donnie character you
just say it's like okay just serve a
general thug kind of thing and you just
sort of straight up thugs are not that
interesting to me even if there is Kevin
interesting were all around him so he
said Donnie because of all you know
you're an asshole I know
I got nothing else that's okay we still
love you
I don't Oh
final words